I'm Jim Kloet.
I manage a team of data
scientists in Chicago,
and I am here to talk
about garbage data.
But before I talk
about garbage data,
I want to lead you
off with a quote.
A lot of you have probably
seen this quote before.
It's about statistical models.
That's from the famous
statistician George Box.
And he wrote a bunch of times,
at least the first part.
All models are wrong,
but some are useful.
But then sometimes he'd go
on and he'd add things like,
so the question you need to ask
yourself is not is the model true?
Because it never is, but
is the model good enough
for this particular application?
And I love this quote.
It's true. It's not
explicitly about garbage data,
but it turns out that you
can just cross out models
and replace it with data,
and the quote is still true
because all data are wrong,
but some are useful, right?
There's no such thing as a
perfect data collection tool
or data retention tool.
And so the question
that you need
to ask yourself isn't,
are the data true?
Because they're not, but
are the data good enough
for this particular application?
Right? And so in this
sentence that I'm thinking of
is us data professionals.
And depending on
where you're at,
whether you're an
industry or academia,
the titles are going to differ.
It could be a data scientist
or engineer or architect
or academic researcher.
The point is, though,
that we data professionals
are often the primary
deciders of data usefulness
in our organizations.
And a typical workflow,
at least for me,
kind of looks like this.
So we'll have some stakeholders
that are super enthusiastic.
I use a lot of emoji, so
if you don't like emoji,
you should leave.
So stakeholders will
be really enthusiastic.
They'll come to us
and ask for help,
like they brought us some data.
And I don't work in agriculture.
This is a metaphorical
Haystack, right?
And so then we
spring into action.
And we think, OK, cool.
Where on this hypothetical
continuum of data usefulness
do we think that
these data should fall?
And if they're maximally useful,
right? The best case scenario
is that they are just
chock full of
insights, which you
see the metaphor keeps going.
Now we've got needles,
answers to our questions,
solutions to our problems,
whatever the stakeholders are
looking for.
Because, I mean,
ultimately, stakeholders
expect that there's going to
be something in data, right?
Like that's the
promise of big data.
And so even if we
make this assessment
that data are minimally
useful, the expectation
from our stakeholders is still
like there's non-zero insights
in there, right?
Like that there's
at least a needle
in the haystack or two needles.
And again, people are led to
believe that data are always
going to be the solution here.
They're not going
to be the problem.
But I think Meghan's
talk highlighted,
Max Kuhn's keynote this
morning also called out
data aren't always useful.
And in a lot of cases
data are just garbage.
And garbage data are
at all of our organizations.
I think if you've
worked with real world data,
you definitely have
encountered garbage data.
And so you know,
then, that garbage data
is problematic and has costs
and can lead to real problems
within our organization.
So my talk here, I
want to make sure
you all walk away with
at least three points.
First, I want to make sure
you can identify garbage
data in your organizations.
Second, I want to make
sure that you're aware of
and can identify the
costs of garbage data.
And then finally, I want to make
sure that you're taking action
when you see garbage data.
All right.
So in the first point here
on identifying garbage data,
so we think an
operational definition
is a good starting point.
And garbage data, I
think simply are just
data that aren't useful for
a particular application.
So if we have
stakeholders coming up
to us, then the first question
we really need to ask them is,
are the data that you're giving
us that we're working with
relevant for the questions that
you're interested in asking?
And so say our
stakeholders come up
with questions about
hot dogs and then they
give us data like this.
And it's adorable and
it's possibly useful
based on just the simple
dogs being in their-- hat tip
to Hadley for this joke, by
the way, in the feedback.
Thank you, Hadley.
But as we're making our
decision about how the data are
useful or not, it's quite
likely that we'll probably
say, no, these data
aren't relevant
to the particular application.
They're likely not going to be
able to answer your questions.
But our questions usually
don't stop there, right?
We've identified
the garbage data,
but garbage data
aren't always garbage.
They could be relevant
for a different thing.
So the next question we want
to ask our stakeholders,
is there another
application where
these data could be relevant?
And so if your stakeholders
are anything like mine,
they have lots of questions.
It's not just that
their questions
are about hot dogs or
one thing in particular.
Oftentimes the data that
they have are probably
relevant to something else
that they're interested in.
And so working with
them to find out
if there's another question
that the data can be helpful
in answering seems like
is another reasonable step
to take.
I think that there's
one other step
to take after this, though.
Say you say no and
the data are not
necessarily useful for
the secondary application.
I think it's safe
or fair to ask,
are there reasons to expect that
these data are total garbage?
Because, again, we've
worked with real world data.
We know that there
are definitely
cases where your data are
not useful for anything,
and that often requires
us to put on our sleuthing
hats, which is usually a part
of any data professional's
arsenal.
I'm not going to go
into all of the ways
that data can be
totally garbage,
but I'm going to walk through
at least a few examples
because I'm sure that they
will resonate with some of us.
Meghan also had a ton of
awesome examples in her talk
as well, so check out
that repo. So things can go
wrong during data collection.
I used to work with
handwriting data.
Sometimes that
data is illegible.
This is not data from any
of my previous studies.
This is actually
from a New York Times
article about kids handwriting.
But the point I think,
is still well-taken
that sometimes the
data is just completely
borked from the
point of collection.
It can also get screwed
up in retention.
Right?
I've had a weird case
where some of my data
were corrupted from a hard drive
failure, but not all of it.
And it didn't become
clear until I'm
doing a little bit more
digging and reading
a whole bunch of logs, which is
not my favorite way of spending
time.
And so retention is
another opportunity
for things to really go wrong
and make your data totally
garbage.
'90s kids.
Steve Urkel.
So a lot of times
the total garbage
results from someone
accidentally borking the data.
I have done this more
times than I can count,
and if there's anyone in the
room who has not accidentally
borked their data to make
it useless or very close
to useless, raise your hand.
Well, actually,
don't raise your hand
because it's going to
happen sooner or later.
So just be prepared
for that sort of thing.
So people make mistakes
all of the time in data
collection and retention,
and so that's sometimes
how data will become
totally useless.
I think a recent
case is where we
had a lot of data that were
replaced by default values.
And so when it looked
like 99% of our sample
were default values,
we had to start
wondering if that was going
to be useful for inference.
The last case,
which I think makes
a lot of news and headlines,
is that sometimes people
intentionally bork their data.
This is what I think
we used to think
cybercriminals looked like
maybe this is what they actually
look like.
I'm not sure.
I don't necessarily think
that this is the most common
scenario, right?
People usually seem to be
honest in my experience
with their data, unless they're
really incentivized to have
data look a very specific way.
So I guess if those
cases are arising,
which I don't think I've
ever had in my career, that
might be an opportunity where
totally garbage data could
be arising.
So in those cases,
what do you do?
You've identified that the
data are totally garbage.
Those need to be destroyed.
I think in most cases. I can
point to a number of times
when I've worked with folks that
have tried to make inferences
from totally garbage
data, and we'll
get into the consequences
of those in a little while.
But if you can't put up
or if you can't totally
destroy the data, put
up as much warning tape
as you possibly can because
you want to make sure
that nobody else is trying to
accidentally make inferences
out of this.
So identifying data is useful,
identifying garbage data
is useful.
But I called out that
there's a reason to do it.
And it's because garbage data.
Oops excuse me, I
had a summary slide.
So summing up part one, some
garbage data use not useful.
Some garbage data are
useful for other stuff.
Some not useful for anything.
So why do we care?
Well, it's because
garbage data have costs.
And I think of those costs in
a couple of different ways.
I think, first, of
these unavoidable costs
that you're going to have
any time you have a data
project, right.
This is just example cloud
bill, because every time
you have a data
project, you're going
to incur costs with
data collection,
data retention, any kind of
support around those data.
There's always
going to be a cost.
Your data, like your cloud
provider doesn't know,
probably doesn't care if
your data are garbage,
those costs are going to happen,
whether your data are good
or not.
You might not be able
to avoid some costs,
but the avoidable
costs, I think,
are really the
ones you have to be
on the lookout for
because that can really
torpedo your organization.
So first, the excessive
regular old data costs, right?
If you don't catch the fact
that you have garbage data,
well, you're just going to
keep incurring bills and bills
and bills and they add up.
And I suspect that in a
lot of organizations that
are bigger than $7,400 a month.
So if you can catch garbage
data when it happens,
that can save a lot of costs.
Opportunity costs, I think, are
another really important one
to call out that are
probably a lot less
easy to point to because
they're not tangible.
They didn't happen.
You can't say I missed this thing.
Right? But philosophically,
garbage data necessarily
doesn't have any value.
So any time you spend
looking into it,
is time you should have been
spending doing something else.
But we're practical.
We're not here for philosophy.
And so like from a
practical perspective,
you see that there's a
lot of interesting things
that you could be working on
as a data professional instead
of plumbing the depths
of these garbage data
and trying to validate that
your stakeholders might
be able to find
something or might not
be able to find something.
And I think that leads
to another level of cost,
which are these people costs.
I like to learn things.
I like to help other people
learn things and answer
their questions.
And you can't do that
with garbage data.
And eventually, after having
to work with garbage data
over and over and over
again, data professionals
are probably going to go find
something else to do or go
look for data that may
or may not be garbage.
I guess, as a spoiler,
the grass isn't
greener everywhere.
If anyone's worried about their
organizations being especially
borked.
It's dirty everywhere.
But people will continue to
look if the data that they're
working with isn't allowing
them to learn things.
And I think that leads to
maybe the most obvious kinds
of costs, which are
decision costs, right?
Because if you're making
decisions with garbage data,
you don't know what's
going to happen. Right?
Like you're making
decisions basically
with random noise
in a lot of cases.
And that means something
good could happen,
but not because of any
smart things we did.
But lots of bad things
could happen too.
And that's why I
think that ultimately
these avoidable costs can
really be catastrophic.
Right? So if you think about
making bad decisions after all
of your data
professionals have left
looking for greener
pastures after having spent
all of your money and retaining
a bunch of garbage data, that
feels like a recipe for
disaster for an organization.
And so the costs can really,
really, really add up.
Garbage data is
something that we need
to care a great deal about.
So now I'm remembering
my summary slide.
So in summation, part two,
think about garbage data costs
in a couple of different
ways unavoidable costs.
You're going to have those any
time you have a data project.
Avoidable costs, though,
can be catastrophic.
So finally, we
should take action
when we see garbage data.
What does that mean, though?
So we're the primary
deciders of data usefulness.
The first thing I
think it means is
when people come to
us with questions
and bring us some data, we
have to be honest with them
and direct with them.
I know that I don't like
to give people bad news.
At various points in my life
People have called me Jim the
dream crusher, and I felt bad.
It was a joke, but
I felt bad about it
and I don't want to
be in that position.
But the consequences of
not being honest and direct
with your stakeholders
and letting
them know when
garbage data happens
are a lot worse than the
consequences of having some bummed
stakeholders right now.
We don't want to bum
any stakeholders out,
but again, I think that we are
obligated as the people who
are kind of the line of
defense against garbage data
to say this is garbage.
My five.
OK, cool.
So the second thing, right, we
don't want to bum people out.
I think we need to
lead with empathy.
And this probably
is just kind of par
for the course for
most of us, but it's
useful to say it explicitly.
Our stakeholders have a lot
of things that they need.
Our stakeholders
have demands on them,
they have pressures on them.
They're not using garbage data
or asking us to play around
with garbage data
because they think
that it's a good way for
us to spend their time.
They're asking us because they
need our help for something.
And so if we're not
leading with empathy,
we end up with
salty stakeholders
who don't want to
work with us anymore.
And working with
salty stakeholders
is a good way to not
have a job anymore,
or be a professional, a data
professional anymore.
Another useful
thing to try and do
is if you can influence
your organization
to treat all problems
as data problems
from the very
beginning. All projects
should be data projects until
otherwise kind of considered.
So default to treating
projects as data projects.
So an ideal workflow
is when my stakeholders
come to me with questions rather
than coming to me with data
that gives me the opportunity
and my team the opportunity
to evaluate which data
sets might be most
appropriate to help them answer
those questions, which makes it
at least more likely that
we're going to find something
in there.
And again, like, they
may not be as happy
as if you'd given them
a huge pile of needles,
but they'll be grateful that you
didn't leave them empty handed.
And then finally,
I think we have
to be patient
because organizations
are used to doing things
however they've been doing them.
And coming in and saying, hey,
you're doing it wrong is
never going to drive change.
I have made that mistake.
It's a bad idea.
So be patient.
Build those relationships and.
If you do all of this stuff.
Like if you're.
I think the third part here, the
actions that we can take here
is we have to be honest,
we have to be empathetic,
make sure we're treating all
projects as data projects
and making sure
that we're patient.
I think that'll help
us accomplish all three
of these points here of
being able to identify
garbage data, the costs, making
sure that we're taking action.
And I guess to
wrap it up, I mean,
if you do everything I suggest
your data are still going
to be wrong no matter what.
There is no changing that,
but there's a better chance
that they could turn
out to be useful.
And that's our goal.
Thank you all very
much for your time.